week three week four there's no better
time to be around Sims and left Co
because this is when we get frustrated
with human beings we're gonna get a
fiery podcast today Sims this level of
patient has reached zero zero zero don't
worry I won't eat lunch everybody I'll
just sit here and watch film and gosh
thank God we did art yes it is Thank You
Josh this is how I want to start it this
is how I want it everybody out there
Josh's in my ear wondering if this is
how I wanted to start it yes they like
the realness of our podcast yes and I
got cut out of watching one thing a film
to do Instagram moments that I don't
give a damn about you're not a big
social media nope yeah but you did study
what the hell happened in bills Vikes
yeah how did Blake bortles go from Sims
shut the F up - oh that's Blake bortles
do I get does anybody know you only get
blamed when he has the one good game
right when they can't score a touchdown
against the Titans team that you know
they should be scoring touchdowns
against at home right no no I don't hear
about thing I don't hear anyone say
sorry Chris yes then you also watch the
film on how the heck did Pat Shermer get
that kind of a day for Eli yes before
the JJ paint rain came second half and
you watched a little bit of Wentz how
does he look how does he feel and of
course you were watching all day at NBC
on Sunday so you feel for the win scheme
regardless even though I didn't finish
the film because I kept a close eye on
them throughout Simza left go football
fantasy league Odell Rogers just a
little update for you Sims cuz you I
know you have no idea
we are currently beating left coast
crunchy biscuit by 2.3 points he has
Jesse James going tonight right
we have juju should be a win anyway
should be two in one day but we're kind
of like the Bears where we're praying
for a two and one could have a big game
- gosh oh really the field to be open
for them guaranteed to lose you went 2
and 3 damn that's a disappointment well
it was a crazy week it was the bills did
not loose
who do you talk to you wanted to start
the podcast left goes LOX
shitbirds man so let's start there
really quick in the last two weeks I
have gone a record of Sims what's that
record Oh Annie is it really it so Nate
Oh Annie I thought you got one last week
No so here's what I'd like to remind
everybody yep
this happened last year it did right so
what we look for in the gambling
community is an edge you're look I I
said in the Seattle game oh they don't
lose at home in September so it's not
the same see how that's an edge see I
don't want to got that one right yeah
Caroline at home 600 but they're playing
the Bengals fingers are good that's an
edge as a real edge so if there if I
didn't you left go lock them because
what I'm trying to provide people is a
service Chris what I'm trying to provide
them is information yeah what they do
with the information is on them yes
everybody knew the Patriots we're gonna
start slow this year why because they've
started slow the last few years so are
the Saints we work all now on early if
you would have parlayed going against
left koloff's fade me if you would have
taken the four teams against me this
week and you bet $100 on each and
parlayed it right you would have made
nearly $1,500 if you would have been
smart and done it to me for two weeks in
a row like you should have they'd have
nearly $25,000 in their pockets but they
didn't know they didn't fade me they
didn't realize that weeks two and three
left go is an S I like this yes so
listeners so I'm gonna ask you Chris
yeah I've already gone through this with
Josh right I have two options hmm option
number one I do what I do every year
which is I stop doing what I'm doing
right now I rearranged and I go on a
nice little run right there's that
option
there's option two yeah I've never done
this before I stay in it I keep doing
games exactly as I'm picking them and
instead of trying to win
I try to lose by trying to win if that
makes any sense if I keep my same thing
where I look at the same websites and I
go the same information I pick my team
okay so what are you gonna do though if
you change it up and try to readjust
because my dream is if I reduce what I
do is I just stop looking at everything
and then I go I'm being an idiot let's
just pick simply and then I go on a run
I start winning again okay I want that
but here's the thing though I want that
I would love to if at the end of the
year my record is like eight and ninety
right that's special people can make a
lot of money off me if I really stink
what do you think well I don't know I
mean I think if you really tried to
stink somehow you'll do good and then
you're gonna disappoint people there too
so I think you should just try to go
back to the drawing board and do what
you've done the last year the last few
years okay
week two and three are tough I mean I
don't give a damn about the spread I
mean come on
that was ill speeding the bike the bills
meaning my legs being the patron Jags
being the tight Cardinals should have
beat the bear exactly right I mean the
Redskins Packers coin flip game I mean
just you know you go through with it was
yes exactly right so that was actually
when the first notes I wrote down I
wrote Cardinals bills liens this is not
NCAA football in the NFL the gap is not
why yes and we're reminded of it like
every second or third week of every NFL
C I think people think that just because
it's the bills and Vikings that they're
turning on like Ole Miss Alabama or
something like that
and I don't care who you are if you're
the greatest team in the history of the
NFL if you fumble the ball twice inside
your own 25-yard line Kirk Cousins are
giving an open up opening series
touchdown you're gonna be a deep crap it
doesn't matter who you are we are having
Jason Kelsey joining us in five minutes
and that's gonna be a lot of fun before
we get to that he's spicing it is he old
spice old spice in it yes like such an
old spice kind of guy man i he better he
looks like someone if he doesn't use Old
Spice it's gonna be a long day don't
stink
Patriots yes I came in this morning and
I was professing if anybody comes up to
me and says the Patriots are done right
you're an idiot
turn around how many times have we seen
this Chris walks in
and I give him that speech and he goes
no but left call I think they might be
done like I really don't want you to
make this point cuz I don't believe I
don't think they're done I just saying
there's more reasons to panic this year
than other years that's where I think
it's you know there's just um like the
front seven that I thought I was gonna
be impressed with really and the Front's
up and I saw in the preseason hasn't
been impressive so far so I think that
scares me out of the fact that you know
they're still trying to play a lot of
man-to-man and the same defence as they
did last year and they don't have that
other cover corner and without a Edelman
Gronk being a year older it seems like
they've rejected the way they want to
play offensively although I just don't
know what do it what do you mean how are
they playing I just feel like that
they're trying to play more like they
did last night where it's like
traditional I formation we're gonna try
to run the ball and maybe open up
play-action passes and explosive place
through that but Matt Patricia didn't
fall for it and then he took the old New
England page and said well I got Darius
slay so I could put him on the Lib
Dorset and then I'm not gonna let Gronk
beat us and every time it was a big
throw you saw that the plays they
doubled them yeah they're all over the
field
I'm am I not seeing something from Sonia
Michele I was he just not have an
opportunity to make a play yeah I mean
it's ok I think I'm gonna look good last
night I just you know again they're
stuck in between of what they want to do
right now and then when you go three and
out the first three series of the game
and you're not on the field it just it's
hard to get back into a rhythm as an
offense I feel like your big concern for
the Patriots isn't even their offense I
feel like you're so concerned about that
defense we talked about the need for
another cover corner we talked about how
slow they're lying back so slow yes I
mean you saw last night I mean if that
didn't show it just how many times that
carry on Johnson get to the second level
and nobody can tackle no linebackers
there or he makes the linebacker missing
the hole to get six seven more yards
whatever it may be
yeah that's where I thought they would
be a different team this year was just
their size up front now hey they didn't
have flowers last night who else was
they were missing I remember some one of
the guy on the on the defensive line but
I just thought Shelton Lawrence guy that
group of guys would have a little bit
more of effect especially on the run
game defense so last year yeah it was
very similar let up a lot of points to a
few teams early in the year right then
played a Thursday night against Tampa
Bay yeah without Gronk and they eke out
that win right and then we kept
reminding people that from that week on
they were the number one scoring defense
in the NFL yes well what percentage are
you gonna put that Belichick fixes it
because I'm putting it at a hundred
definitely I think the big thing is they
have to play through their offense
that's what they are their offenses
ability to execute controlled the ball
Tom surgical 1012 plays that keeps their
defense off the field and it makes the
other teams have to keep pace so even
last year when we yeah their defense
wasn't good and they get to Tampa Bay
and you know week five it was all about
okay but their offense is working at a
pretty high level here to where you're
always playing from behind because yes
the ball scores a touchdown and that's
what we're not seeing right now and then
people are scoring touchdowns on on New
England right now which we didn't see a
whole lot of I have a conspiracy theory
yeah and then I have a regular idea yeah
conspiracy theory yes Patriots through
the game pages through the game yes okay
the Belichick tank job continues to get
back also also he's doing this for
Patricia and Bob Quinn right takes the
ease off of all the pressure that's been
mounting for the last family not only
that Belichick said why we get rid of it
we're gonna end that seventy game
running back 100 yards streak we're
gonna remove that now it's a good hire
good hire by Quinn they're straight
they're good for the rest of the year
belch echoes I can sacrifice a week
three regular season game I'll set you
up also in the back of Bellatrix my
knees going I know all your secrets I
want to keep you in this job because I
like having NFL coaches that I know
their secrets this is my other theory
yes first game of the year yeah
stand Arnold throws a pick six against
Detroit and then his great the rest of
the way right what if for the Lions the
hole Jets Lions game was the Pick six
game yeah and the rest of their season
is a good season what if they went out
there and the the proverbial pick six
that darn 'old through yeah was the loss
right patrícia
man the opposite of Sam Donald
perience was a hero and then immediately
a goat right and then the rest of the
year cuz I'm just gonna say the Bears I
think I have an issue right now with
their office just other than scripted
plays the Vikings just lost by 21 the
bills when they were favored by 17 and
Rogers is limping around yeah and here's
the Detroit with three possible
number-one receivers a few good running
backs an offensive line that's gelling
and a defense that was able to push
around the last two teams and that birds
not even buying Gooden he wasn't good
last night wasn't even good last night
if you go that Niners game if they count
the punt return or the interception
return they probably win that game yeah
what's his name Theo Riddick catches two
balls there in the last Drive I mean
it's gonna be a very interesting so are
the Lions going to be the Sam darn 'old
of the whole season it interesting
theory it is you know what the thing
that I just that's encouraging is what
you saw they have an offensive line that
has a capability of being road graders
and it's gonna be a little bit of
adjustment and I think we're seeing it
right in front of our eyes because
they've never had to be like that
they've never been coached like that and
that Patricia is going no I don't want
to just because it's first and ten go
here you go Matt Stafford shotgun and
make magic happen he's going no I want
to pull the guard around the edge and
dominate the line of scrimmage
yeah and they got the guys to do it they
should be able to run the football with
that offensive line they really should
be I've invested a lot of pics I mean
yes they have glass Glasgow you know the
kid Taylor Taylor Dekker the right
tackle is on black blanking on his name
hold on I'm gonna beat you to it
oh I'm there right Ricky Wagner is from
Baltimore yeah TJ line they got from
Green Bay exactly they're all good yes
they are so it's really just a
fundamental change to what they're doing
to approach I still not believe it yeah
I don't either because you have to see
him more I mean it was ugly in the 49er
game to where the 49ers kind of let them
back in the game and they kind of made
some plays happen yes so I'm not sold on
it but if they can weather the storm and
not be totally out of it and then wait
for Matthew Stafford to become who
Matthew Stafford in my theory world yeah
is adjusting to this new life of like
total accountability Matt patrician
knowing
style what do you mean I just can't get
in shotgun and freewheel it that's what
we've been doing here and it's like he's
like a deer in the headlights right now
like what I gotta manage the situation
they usually just told me to go be Matt
Stafford it saved the day and I feel
like that is a little bit of adjustment
for a quarterback just talking about
good offensive line yeah just talking
about good foundations whoa the Eagles
in my estimation has the best offensive
line the NFL and the best foundation
and it is anchored by a guy that we've
marveled at for years the most athletic
Center in the NFL and the best speech
giver I've ever heard Jason how are you
sir hey I'm doing great after that intro
BAM we just let you have it you are
big-time well listen thanks he smells
great he looks great he's brought to us
by the new Old Spice beard care
collection you could find the entire
collection beard wash B air conditioner
bierbaum and beard oil only at
amazon.com Jason this is not even
related to this season there was a clip
like two years ago where me and Simms
are in an office and he calls me because
you got to see this play that Kelsey did
I think it was against wash I think it
might have been you pulled out it was a
toss and you almost outran the running
back and you chased down the cornerback
and I just I do you remember that play
because it was I'll never forget it yeah
I think I know exactly what player
taught I think I got a clipping penalty
at the end of it actually and it might
have I ran all the way down field after
a DB and made a bonehead mistake of
giving him a shout on the side of his
shoulder after he really couldn't make
it impact but you know that's it was a
fun play to be a part of but really
bonehead mistake there at the end of it
well you know Jason you can't be too
physical in the NFL right now man
yeah hopefully uh you know I love you no
I know I understand what they're trying
to do trying to keep the game safe and
protect players and whatnot but you know
at the end of the day you got to try and
preserve what's made the sports so
popular what's what fans love about the
sport and the physicality is just
something that
and you can't discourage it too much
because you're gonna start changing the
game completely so I am an enormous
Eagles fan let me get this out then I'll
let some speak this is typical me not
letting you speak and yesterday felt
special for me because Carsten was back
and I he is just such a game changer
that long drive that third and nine play
I think epitomizes who he is keeping a
play alive I'm just curious how
different it felt for you guys coming
out yesterday with him there yeah I mean
he is a special player you feel his
presence right away he's a one of the
most competitive guys I've ever been
around a guy that wants to win every
single day whether it's on the practice
field or on the game field he's a
control freak and yeah I would say in
one of the best ways possible well he's
he's very interested in every facet
what's going on he wants to have control
over you know not just the routes the
blocking schemes all that stuff and he
really like prides himself on putting
our offense in good situations and you
know it was a long grueling process he
had to watch his teammates and everybody
win a Super Bowl without him not to
mention he had to recover from a you
know torn ACL you know it's I was I
think everybody including me we were
just really happy for him to be back out
there and for him to be able to scramble
round make plays happen be the carson
wentz of old and show that he's finally
back it was it was an awesome feeling
being out there with the mission I mean
like okay I mean seriously though did
you expect him to be scrambling around
like that and Game one I mean he'd been
doing that in practice yeah he actually
has been doing that in practice last
last week before he was cleared he was
doing the scout team offense and he
scrambled on and it was a the owner of
his a naked or if it was kind of like a
booed action but he ended up running it
for like ten yards in the red zone into
the end zone untouched and he just had
that burst in that sudden reaction that
kind of showed you like oh you know he's
he's pretty much back well I'm sorry I
didn't mean to cut you off I didn't mean
no you're good I would never cut you off
but but no the other thing is to I'm
amazed I mean I
you've been around the league for a
while now what I'm amazed that is hey
first game back let's just get in the
shotgun and just ride carson wentz to
start the game like I was shocked but I
thought there's gonna be like an easing
in period here's some handoffs here's
some screens it was literally like no go
ahead and carry the offense Carson were
you surprised by that well I think that
I wasn't surprised and the reason I'm
not because it's Carson that's his
personality the moment we started
showing that we were gonna do that to
start the game I loved it I mean all
that stuff was called at the line
largely by him and he just that's where
that control like freak a little bit
comes into play he wants to be the one
in charge he wants to be the one to be
making decisions and that's that's a
attribute that I think makes him one of
the special players that he is you know
not too many guys really you know want
that much control or to be responsible
for that many decisions and he wants all
of that and you know that was that whole
first Drive was kind of like it yo I'm
back this is my team my offense I think
that that was you know kind of his
statement to everybody really and I mean
he went out there and we had our best
start to the season so far it was
awesome I mean if the tight ends it was
great I think one of the coolest
relationships in sports is the
quarterback Center relationship yeah
because they're often two of the
smartest guys on the team but Jason we
need the fact that some guy is this
thick is middle finger up his butt crack
there's that too that you don't see that
in basketball but Jason we've done a
bunch of stuff with your brother Travis
and by the way tell him I said left go
says what's up but okay I see both of
you guys you both have awesome
personalities you're both super funny
and I'm sure that you're you're you seem
like a guy that wants to crack a joke
all the time and here I see a Carson
who's like the control freak like guys
we're gonna win the day I'm a joke
cracker whenever I'm around those guys
it's a little bit weird how do you like
I feel like you balance him out maybe
well there's no doubt that you can't
have everybody being like this uptight
type-a personality you got to have a
good balance on a team to have any fun
but I would say that I'm not always
joking around I know when to be serious
I think that on game day there's very
little joking around out on the field
but um I think that uh you know Carson
has a little bit of a goofy side to him
as well you know it's we have a good
dynamic across the board offensively
Lane Johnson probably being the goofiest
one on the team you know I think that uh
you got to have guys keeping it light
from time to time to let you know that
at the end of the day you're just
playing a game man go out there have fun
all right so Kelsey when you're out
there and you're calling out the Mike
we've been very refreshed by the Colts
young defensive players thus far we
think that Chris Ballard their GM went
and got some interesting pieces Marcus
hunts enormous Darius Leonard maniacs
all over the place who caught your eye
from a young and up-and-coming defense
well Marcus hunt isn't very young but he
had a hell of a game against us he was
doing a he's doing a great job
he was timing up the snap count making
life difficult getting into positions
where it was hard to you know get a half
or a hat you know I thought that he he
played really really well him and Jabal
sheered are probably the two best guys
on that defense they're not too young
but they're a handful for any offensive
line when is the last time you had a
beat your brother's ass a little bit and
put him in a place gosh man it's I've
had in college I had some like I didn't
really beat him up but we had to put in
this place a little bit but the last
time we physically fought was in the
back yard after he finally was able to
beat me in basketball he had just gotten
taller than me and as an older brother I
couldn't take the fact that he was just
kept doing this stupid hook shot that I
couldn't defend and I started following
him every single chance I got then it
ended up being a full-blown fistfight in
the kitchen which culminated into me
landing on top of my dad him him
screaming about his ribs and then that
ended the fight right there but that was
our last major major scuffle for sure
well you guys grow up hockey guys right
yeah
well my brother played hockey and
basketball I just did hockey yeah
has he ever tried to dress you in the
clothes that he wears every once a while
I'll be like in a situation where we'll
be in the same city and I didn't bring
enough clothes to like be able to go to
the places he wants to go of course and
I'll be stuck wearing some pair of jeans
that he brings along in it and I'll look
better than I've ever looked probably in
my entire life but it doesn't feel right
okay can you like take people into what
it's like like as a guy that played
quarterback in the NFL I used to have
moments where I would get underneath the
center and be like man you know there's
a guy like Fletcher Cox three inches
away from his head there's no way he's
gonna be able to snap this ball to me
and block that guy at the same time
without getting run over like do you
ever have those thoughts does anybody in
particular bring those thoughts to you
at times at d-tackle
well I mean there's certain guys that
you know or you know the biggest thing
about getting run over is if some guy
jumps the snap count right while you're
still trying to snap the ball we had
that instance actually Marcus had kind
of the snap perfectly in the red zone
and it culminated into a fumble in this
last game yeah and I think that you know
the biggest thing you do is just try and
tell you where a Kiwi makes the snap
count up a little bit you know try and
keep them honest as much as possible but
there's I mean obviously you know
Fletcher Kasich won against him day in
and day out he kind of gets you used to
having man block somebody who can
physically manhandle just about anybody
and you're trying to you know time up
the snap get your hands on them make
sure you have a strong base hands are in
the proper spot I mean it's your your
explosive I'm kidding Kelsey we used to
watch film of you and Simms would go
this is back in the Chip Kelly days he'd
go I don't get it they don't no one asks
a center to snap the ball and then go to
gaps down and get on the outside
shoulder of and dhama consume like no
one asked their setter to do this yeah
yeah yeah it's I mean you know I have a
certain amount of strength certainly
explosion is one of them I'm just
thankful to be with a group of coaches
that allow me to utilize this
you know I think that there's so many
guys and you saw with you know one of my
best friends Nick Foles you know I think
that you know coaching and and the
positions that guys get put in and
whether they're being put in positions
that cater to their strengths cater to
what they do well that gets overlooked
way too often and you know I've been
fortunate with Jeff Stowell and a guy
that knows what I'm good at knows what I
lack at and he tries to do his best each
game plan to put me in a good situation
and I appreciate that greatly and the
thing we appreciate his Old Spice for
making this possible
yes that's right Jason Kelsey is the
bearded Old Spice guy is doing the
campaign with his brother you've heard
of him he plays tight end he's OK check
out the new old Speights beard care
collection and don't forget Jason's
written a poem and I'm sure it's
beautiful
oh yes that's the poem it just goes go
ahead it's all about delivery knock
knock who's there
your beard collection Jason Congrats on
the wind my man enjoy the season and
keep being the part of the dynamic duo
of brothers we've never seen before I
don't know good luck man keep kickin ass
dude all right thanks guys I appreciate
you choked on your Eagle fandom there
keep I'm in a better mood now our
centers typically like you've always
talked very highly upset yes more
they're like they're like him yeah
really quick witted yes because that's
how they have to be it has to be like oh
it's to Jeff protection y3j protection
they're going in the other way like they
have to be able to get everything so
quickly Marcus hunt really was
incredible he's like a reborn person was
so what is the story of Martha I mean he
went I can't believe we're spending this
much time with Marcus hunt but I watched
the game yesterday was everyone he's
like the Estonian nightmare
I don't know I think he's from Estonia I
just totally pulled that at my butt but
he was kind of non-existent for his
years in Cincinnati I mean not that he
was not existing
six-eight yes 298 right and he's 31 and
guess where he was born
you got it right Clark seen you ah
Estonia yes but he just I I was looking
about there's like this guy's at Norbit
I know he's enormous and it's it's it's
me is like again shows what changes
scenery can do at times yeah along with
like the right defensive coordinator
right he's got a guy he had a sack and a
forced fumble against the Eagles
yesterday yeah he's I mean the Huichol
two sacks against Cincinnati yeah he was
he is disruptive as hell so r68 300 yeah
I know and it's I don't know what it is
the new coaching staff whatever it is
but they've lit a fire under his butt to
where he's got techniques understood
more or knows his role better more or
would it maybe they just tell him to
stop thinking so I wrote down Josh are
we okay Josh yeah I think we're good I
did a back porch session last night just
gonna need to calm down from how bad my
left go locks were and I just started
writing down bullet points and stuff and
one thing I wrote for the the Colts is
Colts are super tough and they're gonna
be in every game this year right and
then I wrote down is was the last play
in the game a message to the rest of the
league
I found it very surprising and we're
gonna talk about Carson Wentz in a
second yeah that they took an Andrew
Luck to have Jacoby Brissette threw the
Hail Mary yeah and my first thought was
if I was an opposing coach and I saw
that I'd go we're gonna jam up the box
because all I saw was T Y Hilton across
the middle yesterday right can Andrew
Luck throw it deep with any accuracy
yeah and I don't know but taking him out
felt like a sign to me well I don't
think don't be too alarmed by it I think
the first thing is this he could still
throw the ball 50 yards and and strike I
mean he did that last week and there was
a pass interference against the Redskins
so he can do that now to throw that I'll
marry you know to get it into the end
zone and comfortably he was gonna have
to throw that 65 yards basically maybe a
little bit more someone around like that
does that make your arm more sore well
nothing that makes us more sore but
maybe he feels like he just doesn't have
the Flex
ability or the range in motion yet to
still just let it you know [ __ ] back and
explode to where you can you know launch
it yeah now he he could do that before
the injury I mean hey on his pro day
like we talked about earlier in our
little meeting or whatever else I mean
he threw the ball like 75 yards in the
air so he is at one time was capable of
that but maybe he felt like it was iffy
from that standpoint right there and
Jacobi / said it was not if he I mean he
threw it and I was like oh my gosh she's
gonna throw it on the back of the
endzone but I would say my big thing
would be don't be concerned with that
that's not gonna be it's not gonna
change our defenses defend them I just I
came away from that game looking at the
Colts and going man that defense is
quick it's fast they can get pressure
and I look at the offense and I go
they're just missing pieces they are
they don't have the guys you know Ryan
Grant's not the number two that's gonna
break a tackle and get in the end zone
and they were also missing Jack Doyle
yesterday and Marlon Mac right I think
the Colts are a problem but Carson Wentz
yes you're right I mean he started off
with a 12-play 79 yard drive where he's
throwing it almost every play and auto
bling the whole way and it really didn't
look like he missed a step and the
carson wentz that I was hoping for was
in that last 17 play drive that took 11
minutes right that third and nine in
Elson Aguilar yeah I said the statistic
before last year third and eight and
longer the average NFL first down by a
quarterback completion was 28% of the
time Carson Wentz was 48 percent of the
time that's about three more first downs
per game yeah and those keep your
defense off the field keep drives moving
three first downs is enormous yeah and
that's what he did yesterday he did he's
he's special I mean I look at like I
said I didn't have enough I didn't get
to finish all my notes but I'll just say
this right away I just wrote my first
thing was literally damn Wednesday's a
stud shotgun put it in his hands off the
bat let's go to me that says like one
thing first of all that means that the
Eagles and like you just heard Kelsey
talk about and the coaching staff they
view him as a guy like hey who's Doug
Peterson been around in his life guys
like Brett Favre they just they view him
as that kind of talent Brett Favre Aaron
Rodgers hey let's not make this
complicated
just put him in the shotgun and let the
spread spread out the field let him see
it he'll make the right decisions mate
right throws but I mean come on man his
first two throws of the game he throws a
laser a laser to the right sideline at
the tight end which was a tight window
but still I was just like wow the balls
to actually throw that and then the next
throw is a laser over the middle -
Zachary
yes into tight coverage with a guy right
there right there and that that to me
just says it all but today high-five my
friend when that happened instead he's
back yeah pretty much that was like
that's all I had to say I mean and then
his movement that's where I was blown
away and it did help the running game
yes like we talked about that last week
well Smallwood was everywhere Wendell's
smart he is going to help the run game
because at the very least you have to
worry about that
Wendell Smallwood should have scored a
touchdown on the past that that he threw
him down the left seam that should have
been a walk in touchdown for a big-time
running back to where that changes the
dynamic of the game and he kind of trips
and falls but I just think your offense
is gonna be so much better so much
harder to defend Eagles are back in the
circle Maurice yeah that was part of the
reason why I picked against the Eagles
is I didn't know we were gonna get from
whence yeah and what I saw yesterday was
oh no he's fine yeah he's fine let's go
to the quarterback that your best friend
lost Jimmy G yeah sorry - all Niners
fans to invest that much money into
somebody and to see it really starting
to click and the time in which it
happens sucked because you go down 35 to
7 to the Chiefs and it's a furious
comeback and the one thing that we
messaged about during the game was look
how wide open these plays are second
I'll Shanahan gets for the Niners the
touchdown of the full-back Sherman wide
open the touchdown a good win
wide open and I'm watching the game
going I can't turn this off because here
come the Niners and the defense was
getting some stops and the Niners were a
good team yeah but he lowers his right
shoulder his throwing shoulder and then
he collapses and I guess his foot got
stuck in the turf which you know I would
love to know if he was on tour at all
that would be my first this is always
your it's always my thing because I know
and I'll might just sum up that quick
stateman they're for everybody out there
most of the NFL takes toradol before the
football game toward all numbs the
nervous system so let's just say you're
standing on a clock right you're you
want to tell your body hey step on the
nine o'clock step there because I want
to cut that way and go that way step
there
well when your nervous systems numb and
doesn't know where it is it messes up
what you call your proprioception so
your brain might say step at the nine
o'clock but then it steps at the eight
o'clock and it wasn't ready for that and
they look like to you Tamia look like
that I would really that's what I would
wonder it's always what I think about
and you know my history with my doctors
and everything everything I learned
quarterback take toradol I would hope
hero and be accurately their way that
was just to sense of it either way so
stupid what he did
what are you doing hmm like realize your
worth to the football team now I mean
the season's over because you wonder
what get five more inches by lowering
your shoulder
that's what's disappointing out of the
fact of course I like the 49ers and it's
my buddy Kyle Shin in but out of the
fact that you know Justin Houston said
it was his fault to a course yeah I mean
you have to know you have to know that
what you are to the team is more
important than maybe diving for a first
down in some certain occasion or
whatever it may be you got to keep the
big picture of the season there and
Garoppolo
I do think was kind of turning the
corner in this game finally to where I
was going this okay he's looking
comfortable he was getting off the first
read and not just staying there in the
pocket and taking sacks unnecessarily so
all those things and I think would just
annoys me too because now I just worry
about whether it filters into 2019 here
he is it's a guy again has not played a
lot of football 10:00 starts right and
we're all acting like he's just this you
know salty veteran who's been around for
a while know he still has a learning
curve to go and now next year he's gonna
have to bat out getting healthy yeah you
know getting comfortable with reps again
and all that Niners are bringing in Tom
savage right now okay work out sure CJ
Beathard yeah guys no faith in it can
this team win any games I mean they can
win games yes but they're gonna have to
have relieved demise without Jimmy last
you know I know I mean that's why they
made the move but it won't be easy any
game with their D
fence and the fact that yet Jimmy's a
definitely a tear or two better thrower
than CJ Beathard you know it's gonna
come on they're running games and I have
to be special and Kyle's gonna have to
be extra special with how he packages
plays and formations and you haven't
either
I have not like anything how do you
think he's I mean how could he not be
devastated how could he not be there -
biggest off season you know investments
are gone before
week three the season's over him and
Jerick McKinnon they just get back a
Rueben foster I mean it's just you know
they've had a lot deal with a lot of
crowd Sherman's gonna be a bunch of
Sherman's gonna be a few weeks exactly
right calf strain what on his kilise leg
right what should I just so again it
just shows you here we are in the NFL
and Rehab is in the Stoney let me ask
you yeah you're gonna eventually talk to
Kyle yeah how do you as a friend you're
gonna want to talk ball you're also
going to know how he's feeling but
you're also gonna want to be like hey
man do you immediately say sorry as soon
as you hear it yeah yeah I usually would
say sorry they just be like dude I'm I'm
sorry man that sucks and he'll make a
comment about it and you know whatever
it is what it is and we got to keep
going like that so just coach - I'll
give coach speak but that's truthfully
what he feels and you know he's he'll
compete he's gonna continue to find ways
to screw over defenses and we'll see
where it goes is there any chance that
this could be a silver lining any chance
that Jimmy Garoppolo gets one year of
sitting in the laboratory with Kyle
Shanahan watching the games going on
picking up more and more the playbook
and he comes out next year with a
robotic eye ready to tear apart defenses
III there's stuff that be gained yes
just i hope it's right but yes hopefully
he is on the sidelines with a headset on
and really getting to hear Kyle's
conversations not only with the
quarterback but what are you saying to
coordinators and other coaches yes why
they're on the offensive side of the
ball so he can he can understand what
Kyle's thinking like I never got to be
that franchise guy but I was getting
close to being that and
one thing I know in that time is I
started to really know after let's say
ten starts or ever like what Gruden was
expecting with certain plays or even
having a feel of like it's third and
three I know he's gonna go to this play
I know it I just could feel the way you
say expectations of certain plays do you
mean which receiver he wants to go to
yes what he's thinking the coverage
they're gonna be in how that he wants
you to manage the play in general all
these little minutiae T's right that
he's talking that you've had
conversations about you know in the time
leading up to that to now where you feel
like I know what he's thinking when you
thinking that call I'm gonna look to the
flat I'm gonna look to why banana
if it's not there I'm throwing it away
like something like that where yeah
you're in his head we were in his head
right uh speaking of quarterbacks in
that game hello Patrick mahomes is not
slowing down anytime soon no Patrick
mahomes and the Chiefs
versus Jared Goff and the RAM which
offense do you think sustains the
success longer gosh I personally okay
and yeah I think that the Chiefs is
harder to defend yeah but I think that
the Rams lasts longer because I think
Shawn McVeigh is that special yeah and I
would say that I like the one-on-one
talent a lot in Kansas City right but
that unit of the Rams right now like I
feel like a lot of the Chiefs is like
finding isolated mismatches where the
Rams I feel like it's a whirlwind and
you don't even know what's happened and
by the way Robert Woods had the ball the
whole time yeah right like it feels like
a more cohesive like together unit yeah
where the Chiefs feels more explosive
yeah I think the their the their hands
down the two best offenses in the NFL
right now the most dangerous right
paints and falcons are interested yes
they are but they don't have that
firepower right and I think I know what
you're saying because I think the Kansas
City thing is it's just a little more of
an unconventional offense to so it's
hard to feel like what is the flow it's
just so many things that worried about
here and there where McVeigh is so
creative but within the traditional
sense of it too
it's like okay pi action deep cross at
her Brandon cooked yes okay play action
and he found the underneath shallow
crust
oh okay play action and damn oh it's the
screen to todd gurley 40 yards up the
sideline that's the part that's where
you eyes it together so well so I look
at their offenses I am more afraid of
the guys on the Chiefs yeah like Travis
cult season a matchup nightmare Tyree
kill we know about Sammy Watkins and I
think that Brandon cooks and and and
Cooper cup and all those guy in Roberts
great dream great trio right
but it's the Curley factor I know every
time Gurley touches the ball he's forty
yards down the field and there's part of
me that I I do kind of wonder they play
the Chargers right okay we've seen their
defense allow a lot of points thus far
yeah they've played the Cardinals we see
what they are and they really didn't
have any offense and they've played the
Raiders right so Thursday night against
the Vikings will be very interesting
especially because it sucks it's being
wasted on Thursday night it's sucks
being wasted on Thursday night it sucks
that Marcus Peters is gonna miss it yeah
it sucks that Aqib Talib might miss it
that's not finalized but Andrew
Whitworth just had minor knee surgery
yeah I know he might miss Thursday - let
alone the fact that you're taking away
the most one of the most inventive guys
in the sport four days three days from
them to be more inventive I mean that's
what I think people are missing on the
Thursday Night Football conversation
you're taking away the all the creative
plays throughout the week that we love
to watch on Sunday and all those things
they don't get put into a game on
Thursday because it has to be simple but
you would take what the Chiefs for the
Rams I guess I would take the man it's
so close gosh I guess I would take the
Chiefs but it's the the the the Rams do
have the more traditional good downhill
running game I think they have the favor
there but I think the mahomes Watkins
Tyree kill factor Chris Conley Travis
right it's just a little too special but
they're so explosive
and I'll say where the Rams have closed
the gap and I know I'll watch the film
really deep dive into this on Wednesday
or a Thursday podcast is Jared Goff
Jared Goff is making I'll be the first
to tell you Jared Goff is
was system ish last year okay and the
year before play I like I always say to
left go and years past just silver
platter completions here's you know
here you go Jared Goff here's a 20-yard
in cut on a silver butter if you just
throw it anywhere here to hit the wall
it's gonna be a complete first down and
all those yes they're still there but
he's hitting those with consistency
every time now you don't have to worry
about it and like you and I talked about
a little earlier today he's making
throws that we just go like I go whoa
yes that was 101 miles per hour on the
corner legit zip exactly right so it
seems like watch out for this Rams team
then I I don't want to undersell this
yeah we are somewhat seen you are
somewhat seen as someone that doesn't
like Jared Goff which is never the case
we don't have any personal vendetta at
all but you've always thought that Goff
lacked some of the physical tools yes to
be an elite level NFL quarterback the
last few games your reevaluated I
definitely am I mean if it yes he's
gonna change my thought of this
continues because it's it's not only the
the skills it's moving in the pocket
making a few throws on the run but more
than anything to it's the confidence and
the aggressive decisions that he's
making where I used to sit there and for
lack of a better phrase Vica hug you
will see I mean you had the 20 yard
completion and it was a little tight and
you didn't want to throw it and he threw
the check down and got a completion for
four but man there was 25 yards to be
had there now there's no like he sees it
and he lets it go and I think that's
again offense and I really give Sean
McVeigh a ton of credit for that because
I think he's built his confidence to not
have to worry about that because I do
think Jared Goff was a little bit during
the headlights because of his first year
I wanted to deal with in that crap
offense under Jeff Fisher I believe I
wrote down the five quarterbacks that I
think are playing best in the NFL right
now let me hear it here are my five I
like and I'm not including Fitzpatrick
and Big Ben because they played in that
yeah ok cool ok I'm excited for that
tonight mahomes yep golf right Matt Ryan
mm-hmm drew Brees Cam Newton I mean it's
it's those I think
of the five quarterbacks right now and
of course screw everybody's rankings
it's necessary but like Rogers was on
one leg Kirk Cousins said you're saying
but for those guys of impressive stuff
yes I hear you last eight trips in the
red zone for the Falcons they've scored
Drew Brees I have a hard time when I
like the fact that he really only has
Michael Thomas and Alvin Kamara right
and they're still putting up that many
yards his control of an offense right
now it's master class status it's what
I've always felt like professional
athletes one it's when you still have
enough physical tools to take advantage
that your brain is so much more advanced
than everybody else the spin move was
fantastic amazing amazing just to full
speed
NFL defenders coming at you and you put
them in the spin cycle with a dive it's
so funny too deep the defensive guys
just can't help it they're like I want
to come yes but with Drew Brees to me
it's it there's not a lot of guys I
think two things that can run Sean
Payton's offense the way Sean really
wanted to and the second would be to
keep his body in that kind of shape yeah
it's the aspect of Drew Brees that no
one talks about you're right he's in
better shape than Matt Ryan he's in
better shape than Jared Goff you know
he's he he has the physical tools I
can't remember who was announced in that
game yesterday was that Chris Carter in
that game it was was Chris Carter he
takes a shot at like Tom Brady at one
point he's like he drew brees he doesn't
need all this avocado ice cream and
stuff but he does like he does a lot of
the right things he just doesn't feel
like he's got to tell everybody about
yeah the shot at Tom out of nowhere but
I agree with you his athletic abilities
always been understated and again I know
everybody in the world thinks I'm a Drew
Brees hater yeah I don't think true
Brees is one of the five best
quarterbacks in football anymore
I do think he's top ten and I think he's
awesome and he can be surgical and all
the things that you we talked about you
know even like what Mike Lombardi talked
about a little last week you know that
offense they got to keep up with Drew
Brees yes he's on another level he's
like an extension of the coaching staff
and yeah they're rolling right now and
the real
this is the real gem of the whole thing
the Saints are two in one yes and
they've played average football to me
that's always a sign of a good football
team when you don't really play your
best but you got the win you're gonna
come out two and one like I would say
watch out when they start to get it
going and right they might be able to
rip off four or five in a row and also
mean look up and go damn they're nine
and two well I will say this they are
going to have that stretch if you
remember before the season I talked
about their schedule yeah weeks like
nine through 14 get real tough a lot of
prime time games a lot of big time
matchups yeah you want me to really it's
it's week seven after their bye week it
gets real yes now luckily for them they
have Mark Ingram back huge piece for
them huge they definitely but listen to
the schedule but after the bye week it's
at Baltimore Raven tough at Minnesota
Viking tough home against the Rams like
that's what I'm saying
at the bangles tough home against the
Eagles home against the Falcons yes to
Dallas Cowboys and that's why I had the
Saints falling behind the Falcons this
year is that stretch for the Saints is a
murderer
murderers real I also wrote this down
speaking about the Ravens yeah I didn't
the Ravens might go eight no at home
this year they are a different team at
home they feed up the Broncos and they
beat up the bills and then the Bengals
game was on the road and they started
off slow and came back but I still feel
really good about our Ravens I think we
should I don't but at home they are that
offense Joe Flacco is just different at
home it certainly seems that way I mean
their offense at least is fun to watch a
little bit now it's just not dink and
dunk he's aggressive Marty morning wag
seems aggressive I'll be excited to
watch that film and yeah I'm not giving
up on the Ravens by any stretch of the
imagination I think that we were wrong
about Dallas I think we're okay - and
your offense doesn't look good in the
defense you know they got all these
great pass rushers but you can run on
them because they're all pass rusher
they are all faster mom the the Cowboys
still don't run the football enough let
me just say that real quick as we're
here I mean even in the first half its
first down Ripoff for seven and then
it's passed on second and pass on third
and then the next drive they come out
it's play-action pass on first and then
it's oh damn we didn't get anything on
that play-action pass so it's second
intent and we'll throw again like I
still don't think it's enough I he was
phenomenal yesterday he was averaging
like eight yards and their whole line
was having their way but they go to many
spurts of not giving him the ball or
just imposing their physical will when
it's on the seek yeah Zeke and the
offensive line just annoying I mean yes
16 for 127 he should have got 16 in the
first half of that game that's where I'm
annoyed with Dallas right now they are
annoying yeah uh Panthers Cam Newton is
feeling it you can see it I'm a firm
believer that it's proven that if Cam
Newton starts a game off well they end
up winning the game he's just a momentum
guy I'm a firm believer that that
applies to the season as well the
Carolina Panthers have been doing this
without Thomas Davis he's back in Week
five yeah so I expect the Panthers to
have a run later this year and the other
team that I think people might be
writing off and they're gonna do it the
wrong way
yeah as the Chargers yeah think about
what the Chargers have played night no
they played the Chiefs and the Rams in
two of the first three weeks so let's
not get on them too hard and they don't
have coreihl Egypt he's gonna be back in
two weeks and Bosa will be back yes the
Rams were able to run whenever they
needed to to ice that game the Chargers
will be fine there unfortunately gonna
have to do what the Chargers always do
which is go on like a seven-game winning
streak and then ikan to the playoffs
right yeah I know
the Rams own line is one of the pleasant
surprises of the year hopefully
Whitworth surgeries not too invasive but
yeah damn I mean the bull how about you
know white boys Supreme Christian
McCaffrey oh wow just between the
tackles running I mean that's really
kind of the one thing we hadn't seen
through his career yet and maybe the one
question I still had about him was can
he be that Bell cow guy and you know he
shut that crap up yesterday he and I got
a I'm not gonna lie I didn't get to like
that game I did not focus on know hugely
so a lot of Germans right down to the
Thursday pod Bliss yes
Carolina I know how to down save Jackson
yeah I hit a big interception
I mean he's um he's phenomenal alright
so I ranked the rookie quarterbacks
and I want to know if I'm right or not
okay I went yeah even though it's kind
of super early for two of them
it's all how they've looked yes my top
tier right is Baker and Josh Allen yep
okay my second tier is Sam darn 'old
then Josh Rosen right then Lamar Jackson
right then Mitchell true risky I know
he's not a rookie yeah
but that's where I am with Mitchell's
risky okay that's that's okay
I mean hey listen yeah there's why do I
feel like Baker and Josh and Sam are
already ahead of Mitchell too risky I
don't know why you feel that way I'm
disagree I I mean I think the thing that
Baker Baker and Sam might be a little
bit more natural quarterbacks right
we're sure Biscay is just more of an
athlete who plays quarterback and that's
the big thing we're gonna see going
forward just like with Marcus Mariota
that was always my issue he's an athlete
a quarterback and said of a quarterback
who's an athlete like Aaron Rodgers is a
quarterback who's an athlete
deshaun Watson is a quarterback who's an
athlete Carson Wentz is a quarterback
who's an athlete and then there's that
other flip right where we go damn are
they just they were all these good
athletes growing up and the coaches said
you be the quarterback because you could
kind of throw it and if went in trouble
you run around yeah yeah I I think he's
playing worse right now too risky than
he did last year and I I'd it is wild
and I mean I want to feel like he's a
little bit just the whole situation
Chicago the coaching staffs in his head
and he's overthinking things to a degree
because he still does make some throws
in some plays where I go damn that was a
nice throw I see that yeah he was more
in control last I think so it seemed
more point it's like they took his his
you know guts away or he just they're
they're making him question himself a
little bit I didn't think he looked like
this last year no with the cryptic talk
to that we saw last week in the Monday
Night Football game and all that that's
kind of what I would think just by some
of the crap they talked about but yeah
those turnovers were bad and that's why
you lose a left Cole aw a lock it's
little things like that again the Bears
were clearly the better football clearly
as they played you just said damn when
are they going to take the lead when is
it going to happen that way more this
home right and it took a little while
but they finally got there and yes
early turnovers were were a big reason
why that game was so close so I have a
new relationship oh yeah it's romantic
let me Thursday night I really wasn't
expecting it really and then kissed me
right on the mouth oh my gosh you're
cheating on Sam already Baker Mayfield
blew me away ah I thought you'd liked I
love saying redheads this is the thing
that it's funny it goes back to like the
Jarek off true breeze thing we were
talking about just because I like
someone doesn't mean I dislike someone I
I know I mean I think Sam is being
unfairly judged right now I think that
when a quarterback has a 14-nothing lead
and his defensive minded head coach is
saying let's protect the ball and then
all of a sudden that defense of mine is
coach's defense just allowed two
touchdowns and they go back to the
quarterback and say hey just kidding win
the game it's really hard for any
quarterback let alone a rookie
quarterback yeah but Baker can do things
that Sam can't and one of them was that
seam throw in between the linebacker and
the safety Baker is is the package
he's the package and John Dorsey is
sitting back on hey buddy boy hey I told
you buddy boy right but Baker that was
that was special man I mean to come in
down with with the whole city and
there's a possum loose in the stands and
you that was yeah down down team to
three and to a defense that's been
destroying the other quarterback that
you share a Winnebago
it goes back to what we said first of
all a Thursday night didn't show you a
quarterback who's playing not to lose
and then a quarterback that's playing to
win like we talked about last week but
man you're I mean you're right first of
all Baker Mayfield to me looks like a
shorter Brett Favre out there I mean
just the way Dorsey was saying to that's
the way he slings it around and just the
fearless decision-making and I think you
know hey and again Sam did good things
yeah it was a rough night and let's not
forget the Browns defenses as good as
anybody in football like it's real it's
the real deal
yes they shut down the Steelers yes they
shut down the Saints and they pounded
the Jets yes they did and I just look at
the other thing I'll say that popped out
is I mean hey as good as Sam has been
damn you could tell a difference in arm
I mean when Baker came in you said whoa
balls traveling down the TV screen and a
little different speed than everybody be
watching aw it's simple to see really
simple to see exactly it's so simple
that my wife was like like and my wife
you know is clueless I love that you
build it up every time we're all very
well okay your wife makes a comment it's
Rodney the coolest the only reason she's
even paying attention somewhat is cuz
Sam's been on the sims and left go show
Hey she's watching that just and she
goes she knows I like him yes oh oh I
like him too
yeah but she knows Baker may feel a
little from the Hard Knocks and all that
and she's sitting there watching the
other night and I couldn't believe she
looked at me and she's like this is fun
it is fun this is fun like I can't
believe we're watching this like these
young guys doing this and I was like I
can't believe you're my wife wouldn't
you do with her you're usually just
talking about what Yeezys you want to
buy next it sounds like she's been
watching more football she says like
because of us and just like my workload
she's like starting to learn through
osmosis that's great yeah so we'll sit
but you know what else it is yeah
there's a lot of fun quarterbacks in the
NFL right now it's like you go through
and it's funny you know I'd trade it for
Patrick poems and fantasy I'm very
excited but I was talking to the guy but
not on our fan it's not al our fantasy
team we're gonna have to make a move
what do we get I think we're picking up
Ryan Tannehill that's bad but there are
so many quarterbacks that are pretty
talented and I think two years ago where
we're trying to convince ourselves on
the Thom savages the world and and and
all these guys it's the new era man it
is I did a Sims in 60 I don't expect you
to listen about it but I talked about
how like it's it's this Golden Age of
NFL quarterback there's like 20 to 24
quarterbacks in the NFL that can win
it's 30 years of this sport being the
most popular sport in our country and
the best athletes going I want to be a
quarterback and it's seven on seven cams
and I got a quarterback coach and I'm
nine years old and I've only trained for
a football and we're seeing the fruits
of or what are we bearing the fruits of
that labor and I just I think I look at
that and you go damn ok damn but you
know last year is mahomes too risky and
Watson Watson thank you uh and then this
year it's five other guys in the first
round and guess what I can tell you
right now it's gonna be at least three
the more this year because I know the
damn kid from Morgan's going in the top
ten and the damn kid from Missouri's
going very high and the damn kid from
Auburn are going very high let alone
some of those ones that I might not like
the kid from West Virginia he'd probably
be a late round off both hit exactly
like it without looking ahead that's
like ten guys in the last three or four
drafts that are all solid quarterbacks
this is my other out of left Cofield
okay out of 'some stadium this I really
think this might be something going
forward what like why do we have to give
our seventh year quarterback a hundred
and forty million dollars when there's
these studs that are coming up the lines
every year and we're seeing teams be
successful with quarterbacks on rookie
contracts and they're capable of playing
at a high level a la a whence a golf a
Russel Wilson
you know Joe Flacco when he was doing it
earlier so I wonder if that becomes a
thing I do would be wondering right uh
speaking of Josh Allen Josh got his
first start and other than completely
wrecking a left go lock he completely
wrecked a Minnesota Vikings team we're
good at my notes so I have not seen your
notes at all which is probably good from
the outside looking in here's the
perspective well here's my perspective
to Kirk Cousins and fumbles inside your
own 20 led to a lot of the reason why
that game got out of hand quickly but
the Josh alland pump-fake on the screen
deep past was a beautiful play
Josh Allen jumped over somebody that was
everywhere yes when you went bak back
and watched the notes excuse me that
doesn't make sense
oh you went back and now it's the film I
was looking at your notes how was Josh
Allen against a very good defense yeah
he was really good I mean it was it was
the right game plan on both sides of the
ball I think that's the first thing I
look at first drive of the game
hey they got bailed out by what I think
was really kind of a bullcrap roughing
the passer penalty on Josh Allen
surprised right surprised haven't heard
of those I mean so that was that
extended the first Drive and then they
go down this
field and score a touchdown I can't
remember the first touch Oh Josh Allen
runs to the left
brakes contain through the left side you
score a diving touchdown where I believe
I wrote damn you know you're fast when
you can outrun bar with the ball in your
hand to the corner in the endzone I mean
he outran Anthony bar with the ball on
his hand you're telling me he outran
Anthony bar right and then jumped over
Anthony but yeah I mean and Anthony bar
is like a top set like top ten pick
because of how physically gifted he is
exactly right I mean six five to 55 and
can run and jump and do all those things
so I think just from what we saw they
managed the game correctly they ran the
ball they threw screens they got the
ball out of his hands quickly and then
they had some nice wrinkles off of it
but a lot of the big plays were because
of him and his athletic ability yeah can
i prod your brain yeah all right you
were about to witness left go milking
Sims arm strength arm strength is
through the roof
I mean it's it's up there with you know
the Favre's in the home I mean Rogers in
the home how is he reading the Vikings
defense yesterday he was good they made
the game simple on him well it just it
was very basic like okay here's a
bootleg it's to the flat or to the cross
or if it's not there you run or throw it
away you know here's a three step
passing game if you got single over here
it's just gonna be a six yard hitch
route throw a rifle over there and get
it done with it being that simple yeah
people gonna be able to figure that out
or is his ability able to overcome no I
think their people are going to be able
to figure it out because again they
don't have the weapons to go along with
it that's scare you but his ability is
going to keep them into football games
they that game would have got close if
it weren't for his ability to make magic
happen escaping out of the pocket and
either running for a first down or
escaping out of the pocket and then
dumping the ball off to a Chris Ivory
where the the defenders are like well
what do I do we've been covering for
seven seconds and now he's about to turn
the corner so I have to go run up and
tackle him
oh there's Chris Ivery behind me a
number of time a number of times his
running was the difference in the game
it's what kept the lead it's what kept
the ball in their hands and it's what
extended drives to where he can make a
play with his
or somebody else could at some point
it's very early from what you were
watching with him in college to what you
saw yesterday in his first start yeah
we're how far has he come is that what
you were expecting to see I it is it is
what I'm expecting me you know I've been
high on I thought he polished himself up
a lot just from where he went from the
end of the season at the Senior Bowl in
the combine so I still think we're
seeing that in the right way out of the
fact that he's got a scotch and
McDermott who knows how to manage a
football game and knows how to
communicate how he wants that game
managed to a guy like Brian day ball
who's from New England who also
understands that theory as well so the
bills are back for playing smart foot
they were and the defense echoed that as
well what about you I guess you watched
it I did i watch both sides so do they
just destroy the Vikings o-line for the
most part they got them and who did it
well I mean Jerry Hughes certainly back
Jerry Hughes whooped the crap out of
Riley Reif on that side also they did a
few nice little stunts to where you know
they put the Milano kid outside Jerry
Hughes so now the back is outside Riley
Reef and as soon as the back committed
himself Milano came underneath and what
happened a few times is Marie actually
almost hit Reilly wreath and stopped him
from being able to stop please get
around the edge but they are smart and
if I wish you got to read my themes
because one of my themes of this weekend
was the five man pressure which is what
a [ __ ] waste it is I mean whether it
was the the Texans doing it to the
Giants and wide they were tearing them
up but they rushed for change coverages
and just basically once they got that
lead didn't take any chances and said
huh we're just gonna see if your offense
can execute and we're gonna drop into
some zones and we think we have a read
on what your concepts are and they did
that correctly blip for the Vikings or a
big problem moving for I I think you are
like me I'm not sold on the Vikings I
want to be but I'm not
I know exactly right offensive lines
what scares offensive lines an issue I
mean Everson Griffin's out and they are
a different defense line so that was so
how big of a loss was ever seen I mean
it's a huge loss it's a it's like their
defense never really they would have a
guy like him would have stopped Josh
Allen from a two or three of those runs
where you just got damn he's not gonna
get around the corner if that's Everson
Griffin where you know he might have got
around the corner but ever sink or if I
want to caught him from behind whatever
states could be fascinating it really
will be because the interior offensive
line for the Vikings against Donald and
soo and then all the injuries for the
Rams right now right I'm curious have
ever seen Griffin's back I I would be
interested to I mean that's how I feel
like did they rest him and David Cook
just for that game but that would be my
finger overlooking it like you know I
think we can get away with this one
let's get ready for the Rams the next
week and that's when you get your ass
whooped in the NFL so how long does this
bills good fortune last um I know it's
gonna be tough I mean it's it's gonna
have to go though game's gonna have to
fall the right way for them it's gonna
have to be the red they're just not that
talented right but this was one of those
games about the five-man rush to that I
want to get to sure how many times the
Vikings rushed five I mean I just don't
get it you know and then and then okay
typical of them and it can be typical of
them yeah they're people that that are
not understanding why this upsets sim so
much teams have five offensive linemen
so if you're gonna rush five which means
you're putting yourself at a
disadvantage with receivers and running
backs odds are you might not even get
pressure with the five right because
you're kind of going even on even and
one guy gets knocked out of the way and
all sudden there's this huge hole there
and there's less guys to actually now
look at the running quarterback and go
tackle them cuz that linebacker is stuck
in the line of scrimmage just he was the
fifth rusher and you've always said that
when you pass rush five it's like you
want a blitz but you're not like kissing
your sister yes what it is it's kissing
your sister for gonna blitz blitz six so
absolutely simmer I didn't expect simmer
to be like it really simmer someone that
when he brings five he disguises it yes
two guys in the a block right in the gap
one guy drops the other one comes and
it's a it's a hidden fire yes it can be
a hidden five this game was not and then
the other thing they just didn't prepare
for was yeah okay yeah you might have
five and your coverage you guys might be
able to cover them but you know what
they forgot about that number seventeen
has a freakin holitzer for a right arm
and even though your defense was right
your defenders were like holy crap that
ball just went right by my hand
and it's a completion and that has to be
taken to account when you play
quarterbacks like this all right so we
have some questions about the Vikings
excited about the potential of Josh
Allen yes but this is not gonna be an
every day every week thing mainly
because of his weapons and cousins was
off not just the fumbles throws after
that it's amazing that's a guy traded
from a homes yeah I have cousins yeah
cousins missed some throws in the game
where when the game was still in the
balance 14 nothing 17 nothing where you
go okay he hits this deep crosser right
here two Thielen they're gonna they're
gonna be back in this game and then feel
good and he he just missed some throws
where I was like what the hell was that
were owing to heading into Sunday were
four and one against the spread the only
team that that didn't yes was the
Raiders and the Raiders had that game
tight bills Vike Vikings playing from
behind will be interesting as we go
forward not a good play for mind I just
I I mean I know the girls off in Green
Bay but Green Bay had chances I know
those also think of Aaron Rodgers
healthy of that game that when it never
came to that but yeah because of their
low line that we've talked about left go
like if you if they're playing from
behind and you know they're gonna throw
the ball every play they're gonna be in
trouble right you were just talking
about the Packers yeah Clay Matthews and
the hit right I saved it for now because
I wanted to have some discussions
because I feel like everyone's
discussing this first Clay Matthews
third week in a row third week in a row
it's a roughing the passer the first one
he deserved it yes a Chicago one then
the game against Minnesota with Kirk
Cousins and now with Alex Smith he gets
called for the bodyweight pass rushing
penalty I joked earlier that for his
whole career he's been made to look
faster because of his hair I have a
theory that if you have long hair it's
great rail it's a tracer you look faster
and that may be the hits look making a
little more violent he is also someone
that clearly lifts his legs up to make
the sack and I think it's being
interpreted that way this time he rolled
over put his hands I was like look I'm
not putting my weight on I don't think
he's lifting anybody up I just think
when you're 260 pounds and you can you
can squat 500 something pounds when you
run into an object they go off the
ground
that's what I don't that's what's
annoying sorry go ahead and then I'll
right around that time Aaron Rodgers
gets picked up by Duran Payne Northern
Lights suplex down to the ground
all of Doron Payne's 300 and something
on top of him it wasn't called I kind of
I took a picture of it in my phone
because is there any chance that this is
happening because of who the
quarterbacks are and I'm not saying it's
because they're stars I'm saying because
they're small hmm think of the
quarterbacks yeah Kirk Cousins Alex
Smith yeah
when they get hit it looks like they're
gonna explode right you've seen those
guys they're not big guys in person if
Clay Matthews did that to Cam Newton bet
you it's not called I agree didn't him
Carson Wentz any yes I feel like when I
saw Alec Smith get hit his whole body
was like I'm a little I'm a little
teapot and then clay went on him and I
think visually right it looked like all
of his weights on this little guy yeah
then we have William Hayes tears his ACL
apparently trying to sack and not put
all of his weight down so it's an issue
we've had 30 rough in the past or
penalties called already it's an issue
in every single game how upset are you
I claim Matthew says the NFL is getting
soft they are it's disgusting it's
stupid I'm all for player safety like
I'm all for it but I don't even
understand what you're what's expected
here there they have to rewrite the rule
to a degree and go back to the drawing
board just like they did with the helmet
rule in the preseason it has to happen
it's we're here to protect the
quarterback sure if Clay Matthews was
picking guys up and then like
deliberately driving them the ground
yeah that's one thing but these are like
perfect form tackles textbook head to
the side shoulder in the chest yes and
then just running through the object
that's what he's doing and when you're
64 to 60 and you run through an object
they tend to come off the ground
aza Alec Smith or occur cousins who were
6 3 to 15 or whatever it may be it's
it's if that gets ruining the sport to a
degree I I can't I don't know what else
to say
at the
quarterback doesn't have somewhat of a
fear in the pocket then damn what's the
point even hitting the quarterback
anymore
I just they're taking away a big aspect
of the football game there it's it's
it's just the expectations are not
realistic I guess is what I'm saying
so the point is it's changing the game
the counterpoint would be did you enjoy
the NFL last year did you enjoy not
having Aaron Rodgers and deshaun Watson
and all these guys like the NFL
recorrect it so hard yeah because they
didn't want another year of all the
quarterbacks being hurt oh okay who hit
Jimmy Garoppolo yesterday I didn't know
the NFL could tell the future
suck it they don't know crap okay yeah I
like the NFL last year what I liked it
more of Odell and deshaun Watson were
playing okay yes but which one of their
plays had to deal with this I mean Aaron
Rodgers has to play a reckless style
football or Green Bay can't do crap so
he has to go on the run at full speed
and throw 70 mile-per-hour rocket balls
when he's running full speed because
they can't do anything unless he does he
got caught in a weird situation
yes Shawn Watson when did that happen
right I think I'm really happening see
it happens yeah they got twisted
somewhere but again my point is they
can't control these things I feel like
the NFL's in a no-win situation either
one they're seen as not protecting their
players enough or two they're seen as
again the no-fun League so either
they're not fun and they're hurting the
the the purity of the game or they're
not aptly protecting their players which
I think they're set they're very
sensitive about after the CTE I look
case yeah right I think they are
sensitive to that I think your point
about the quarterback thing is certainly
a part of this but like I'm all for
player safety and it's going in the
right direction this one is overboard
it's not it's not within the spirit of
the game this was made for the
egregiously wrong to protect the
quarterback from when those like a
stupid meathead D tackle who wants to
take all his rage out on somebody does
something that's you know without with
it without or outside the confines of
the rules these were not that and I just
think the NFL has to go back and I
little comments yesterday that was like
even John Mara is not happy with it he
admitted it in the pregame and I'm
watching the Texas Giants game that
there's something has to be done at this
that's not right
so I'm hoping they are going to
self-correct this yeah or maybe rewrite
the language to a degree because Green
Bay's been screwed for sure and not
alone I mean didn't the refs screwed
them but then the other receivers can't
catch the ball and that doesn't help
Aaron Rodgers yeah you were pissed at
their receivers yeah I mean given I mean
he's playing with one leg doing
everything you know Randall Cobb you
can't fumble you can't drop a fourth in
one pass you you Lance Kendrick you
can't drop a wide open 70 yard bomb like
those are things that you know again
that's why you're 1 1 & 1 now yeah I had
you go back and look at Jaguars Titans
whoa I needed to understand how the
Jaguars go from world beaters that force
the Patriots hand to sign Josh Gordon to
keep up with the Munder s attack of
Blake bortles and all that offense just
read through it's not a lot of notes
because it's simple game ok so this is
your notes Jaguars Titans no one's
talking about Blake bortles today I know
where is all my love letters to say damn
Chris maybe you're right maybe that one
in 64 game aberration you you're all
right ok alright the first thing I'm
seeing here yeah bortles throwing ball
crappy I mean it's like we went back
three years I don't know what else to
say every ball was a wobbling duck that
was a knuckleball sinker you wrote
Jaguars had a few drops but tough
catches cuz of knuckleball sinkers yes I
mean I don't know you know spirals balls
like Aaron Rodgers and Tom Brady throw
are easy to catch because they're there
they spin so tightly incorrectly that
they almost dig into the players gloves
and hands to where it's just easy it's
seamless they can just snatch it with
bortles you almost say it's like a
moving target like oh gosh I got a
kitchen like that or this or it's just
it's all over the place you wrote three
men off bail or off ball Bay's so what
they did this is the Titan the Titans
defense well they played the game I mean
they had the breakdown correct what do
we always talk about play areas for
certain teams
I can watch Jacksonville and tell you
the areas they're going to
they're gonna throw if the outside
receiver has a tight split they're gonna
throw a ten-yard out if he's outside and
sees one-on-one prep just man-to-man
press they're gonna throw a fade jump
ball if if none of those they're okay he
might look to the out on the right and
there's gonna be a shallow cross coming
and he's gonna throw the shallow across
and then they apply action just the
crossers over the middle that you see
like a 12 15 yard crosser that every
offense has and then they throw screens
and boots off that because that's so
that's what you really have to defend
and the Tennessee Titans said okay we'll
give you the out routes if you can hit
him which he couldn't yesterday and they
said we're gonna play single safety
we're gonna play basically three deep
and five under and they their corners
played off so you didn't weren't
thinking oh let me throw the jump ball
right and then they had all these people
underneath to to go oh you want the
cross her go ahead fit the cross her in
let me see you how different would it
have been if Leonard fournette was there
well it I don't think it would have been
a whole lot different the Titans the
Titans D can get big if they want like
those numbers I wrote down in their 990
94 and when they get jerel Casey
Daquan Jones and Austin Johnson on the
field they're both you know Casey's the
small one at 305 the other two were 315
and 330 and then you talk about a rack
PO on one end or Derrick Morgan or maybe
it's Harold Landry and camel a acorrea
with the middle linebacker play they can
they so my bottom line with them
Jacksonville is this why do they have
Jacksonville's number because they're a
little more creative than Jacksonville
is on both sides of the football and
they're just physically a good enough to
not be overmatched by Jacksonville which
is what Jacksonville does to most teams
and they took away some of the staples
the just the 10-yard throw over the
middle the shallow crosser and the boots
they always had a guy in the flat to
where he had to do something else and it
made him uncomfortable and it was it was
a bad day for their offense is your
faith in the Jaguar still high it is it
is so high I'm not gonna waiver off of
them do the Titans just give the
blueprint oh stop the Jaguar well yeah I
mean again they would go into like we
always
talk about play areas don't play people
or men but Dean Pease is awesome you and
I both know that we've been talking
about Dean can coach and do things and
other D coordinators don't even know
what they don't know what he's teaching
and I think that's where they're special
that way
let's go 30,000 feet on the Tennessee
Titans yeah they beat the Jaguars by
losing their quarterback that's healthy
to a concussion only kicking field goals
and really using Mario Marcus Mariota as
like a glorified running back yeah in
the second game
they have Blaine Gabbert for the entire
game and they're just getting guys back
from injury and they outlast the Houston
Texans and the game they lost in week
one was a seven-hour marathon that I
don't think anyone's gonna take anything
it's very hard to get a feel for that
Titans
yeah I know what are we working with I
don't know what we're working with like
I know this I think they can play
through their defense like I would be
they don't need to be this offensive
explosion of a football team because of
their corner play their safety play is
phenomenal their linebackers are
athletic we got to see our man the
first-round pick he got in the game of
it he looks I mean he looks the part
does he he didn't play a ton but he
looks the part you know with whatever on
red zone it never came out once because
nobody else but I gotta think that the
Tennessee Titans offense will come
around
especially with Conklin and LaJuan
getting exactly right them the run game
hasn't got off yet of course there's the
the quarterback situation that's giving
no continuity to the offense but little
guys like Taiwan Taylor pop Corey Davis
is popping a little bit weak I saw them
sparring with jaylen Rams oh they can
get that part of their game going
because we know their run games and I
have something to add like they might be
one of these teams every week like they
play your Philadelphia Eagles this week
I know it's gonna be you know they might
be a little too one-dimensional on
offense if they can't get the past game
going to where that's where they lose
the football game but their defense is
gonna keep them in this game against you
guys Wow because they're their cover
guys they're gonna be able to mix things
up and take a chance playing man-to-man
every now and then because they're built
the right way all right so you're you're
sitting there and you're looking
the Jaguars and you go is there a party
that goes man that tightens just know
them so well and other teams aren't
gonna be able to do that yeah I don't
have the faith that everybody will be
able to do that I don't have the faith
that everybody can the first thing you
have to do is just stand up to their
pure brute strength and if you can't do
that
that's where teams get compromised not
having cam Robinson for them uh it was
not a huge issue I didn't look at it
that way but they could never get the
run game off yesterday like you know how
the last week ravages like him there's
no hole but they're still getting five
yards just pushing them back no that
might just be the Patriot that might I
mean it might be I which is odd which is
I'm shocked aback week's pushed around
you sent me a text in like maybe this is
what the Patriots are just don't deal in
terms of I know like being pushed I
thought that was gonna be one of their
strengths it was being able to be big up
front and stop people and it's proving
I'm gonna be wrong on that and then the
other thing I had you look at was the
Giants yeah here's an offensive line
that hasn't been able to do anything and
Pat Shermer dial some stuff up for Eli
in the first half and the offense every
time I looked up was moving the ball yes
what's your takeaway in the first half
especially moved the ball well okay does
that of the Texans this is the yeah this
is the first thing we got to go right
away with okay our guy wheeler who
started for Erik flying tackle yes he
sucked but nobody's talking about that
which is hilarious well no I saw him get
led up three sacks on Aging I just want
to say what if Erik flowers did that
what would the talk be today that's
where I just get annoyed with football I
actually heard I actually heard on NFL
something with Trey Wingo
he was like Eric flowers probably would
have let up the same thing that was his
take maybe maybe he would have could
have been worse I think he said but I
just don't think there's I don't know
about that because I think Eric flowers
could at least stop some of these power
rushes there's no one where Jay Jay just
took hit wheeler and threw him down
there was like a throttle gold fires
right there was some comical plays okay
yes I think the first thing is this
thing early on I wrote they made an
effort to run the ball right so that was
the first thing we saw and man I mean
he's special I don't know what else to
say I mean he just he can take one he
can make cuts and start and stop I'm
almost at the point where I'm gonna go
him and girly are on another level than
the rest of the NFL we're gonna put sake
one may be up there with girl I think so
he's not gonna go Maura no I don't think
you know they're quite the he's not
quite the milkman I still don't think
he's the specimen they are that's where
I think they said we're all ready to put
sake one already up there with curly
yeah it's hard to tackle in a to n touch
game right now I mean he didn't like
about McCaffrey McCaffrey is really good
but I still don't think I can put him in
the physical free class I'll have you
leave a Johnson maybe David Johnson
could be in that trap no he'll be stuck
right right but yes I think they could
be raised for sake well it's pretty
special when you see him turn the corner
and do the things he does but that was
the big thing early on they got the ball
to sake 1 on the run game pulled guards
did things like that and they got the
ball to Odell Beckham jr. in the pass
game so right away the Texans are going
damn its sake qualms we got to worry
about that because he can rip off a 70
yard run on us and damn we can't leave
Odell out there men to man too many
times or he's gonna go 70 yards to the
defense of the Texans is not the same
right now Jadeveon Clowney he's not our
same guy man it's sad and might want to
write sad emoji next to it he's thinner
and he's not as powerful he's been
better each week but he's still not be
to him [ __ ] upper of plays that we
know have come to known in LA yeah it's
just not as disruptive Whitney merciless
the same thing it's better every week
but he's not the Whitney merciless we
saw last year you know you and I last
year we watched the Texans really yeah
rip your head off like the Bears have
been this right right so they're not the
same 99 watt is back oh they howl back I
mean he's back how about this 2% we saw
it a little in the second half last week
yes he is back what are you like we're
talking because he had that run yes I
know I'm gonna say it's there yet
possible MVP in the NFL I'm not gonna go
there but it's going after Michael
Strahan sack record no but it's back to
where I'm going he's in the conversation
from one of the best defense ends in
football right now that's no doubt about
it I mean wow he is sure it's not
because he was up against wheeler well
hey hey that's I don't know but I know
he's getting it in sacks and pressure
it's really ever since the second half
of the page
it's game he's looked like a different
guy Titans gaming this game he was good
this game he was phenomenal on either
side it didn't really matter of course
to know I mean on the other side against
soul so he's back the other guy that's
so impressive for them is honey badger
honey badger looks like the honey badger
that we saw before he hurt his knees
don't care yeah he don't care so that's
awesome
all right now getting into this game but
yeah yeah can I go big picture yeah yeah
are the texans owen 3 bad like because
you kept telling me that they were
dominated in the second half and that
they were you know but how bad are they
yeah well they like i feel like you've
had coaching but they can't get it all
together it's like the first half of
this game which i'm gonna get into and
right in here in a second i just i don't
know what they were trying to accomplish
i don't know what they were trying to do
let's just take this right off the bat
it's 22 9 and Lamar Lamar was a Lamar
Miller that fumble tell that I'm just
gonna forget the who fumbled there Lamar
Miller fumbled as they're going in to
score next tribe deshaun Watson threw an
interception in the end zone so the game
was there to be had like it was there
for a Texan exactly right it's just a
dumb or two or three plays every game
the biggest thing though early on was
what they did to let the Giants get off
what why would did you run they were the
ultimate rush 5 team in this first
Valley this game what why why so Odell
could catch the 4 yard shower cross and
nobody be there as a middle linebacker
and then he can run for another 4 10 or
15 yards I just don't get it they really
played into the Giants hands to go oh
you're rushing 5 yeah we know we don't
have a good offensive line but we have
one of these matchups is gonna be good
for us because we have talented guys and
we're just gonna get it out quick and
sterling Shepard will run for an extra 5
yards or Evan Engram or whoever it may
be so that's what I didn't understand
right off the bat they were killing it
in the short middle early in the game
replacing the fifth Blitzer why I don't
know ok then I other thing I wrote I
don't think I dialed Beckham juniors
totally 100% Odell Beckham jr. yet I
just think he lacks just like a mile per
hour or two on his straightaway
straightaway speed do you believe it's
Nicolle gain back or something he's lied
you think it's something he'll gain back
I do let's he did have a pretty horrific
dislocation broken ankle all of that so
that might not be quite where it needs
to be don't get me wrong he's still
running by everybody but I'm just saying
like he caught a shallow cross in the
game and I've you remember Kareem
Jackson is carrying him hit his toe he
still stayed up but I would have I was
like damn he would have never even hit
his toe last year before the injury and
he would have made the guy miss in space
for a touchdown instead he got tackled
so I just looked at that I wish you
could have read these all right then go
back again and just go short middle open
every time cuz Texans are stupid as [ __ ]
and they have a five man rush every time
why I just don't understand you come
away from Shermer in the first three
games how do you feel about his approach
of this office I like everything about
the offense other than that their
ability to pick up pressures that they
should be able to pick up does not get
communicated the right way is that an
old line coach issue it's an old line
coach issue and something he has to sit
down I thought they were like the center
and maybe that's an issues it could
certainly it's all part of the
communication but they mess up things
that are just too simple and sometimes
have things that I just go wait wait say
Kwan's blocking the three technique in
pass blocking like in Nathan what that
was gonna work like they're they have to
find new ways to do that everyone comes
in today talking about Eli Manning and
the accuracy right how was he he was he
was very good I mean there's he met
about two or three throws that were
legit I was like wow that was a good
throw right there
the seam route for her touchy I threw a
deep out to the left Odell meant to rent
Allison exactly it was great throw those
were right
but everything else played into his
favor everything else was quick and they
kept they kept voiding areas to where he
didn't have to ever think oh here's
sterling Shepherd right in front of me
baby he'll just he just found where the
rusher was almost the entire first half
yes what happened in the second half
that's where we're gonna go right now so
second half
Giants can't move the ball my thing I
wrote Texas blitz though
Texans boot zone change which is they
changed up their looks but didn't blitz
they
blitz but still only rushed for so right
let's say the two middle linebackers
blitz but then the 2d tackles dropped
out so it was still four-man we call I
would call that blitz zone change right
you whatever covered you on a plate but
that's what they did they stopped the
stupid-ass five-man pressures and stop
they started having people there to take
away those easy completions yet that was
a huge thing and that cow is that not
the game plan so start Turing the day oh
no how do you watch the Giants against
the Cowboys and see a million throws
five yards or less I think Eli Manning
was like yeah like 20 completions five
yards or less I don't thing you allow
the Giants to do I feel like it's just
meat headed defense a coach that goes
they can't protect if they go we go five
one-on-ones we're gonna beat them no you
could send three against five and you're
gonna beat them I think that's what they
were wasting their time late and that's
what they started to do but it's so
annoying to adjust to that at halftime
when it's so obvious to everyone in the
world before the game I know I just
really annoys me it's annoying about the
Texans right now it's like their
offensive plan right now is off every
week and then they make the adjustments
in the second half but it's too late too
little too late to where they can't
quite come back all the way and the game
22:15 the games 22 15 yeah and you know
what they did the first play that was 20
to 15 which team the Texans on offense
or d4 they're on defense and the game's
20 and then although I'm at Giants can't
do anything it's the rush 5 Sunda Lee I
don't even know what to say it's
unbelievable first play 20 to 15 they
hadn't rushed 5 1/2 techs and rushed 5
and I wrote guess what
shallow crossed for 30 yards distillery
sterling Shepherd I just don't know what
you're dominating the game and back to
that [ __ ] is what I wrote I just I don't
get it
so that's the story of the Texans right
yeah Giants D played really well
Texans Oh lines an issue they can't rely
on that run game especially against
defensive lines like just telling that
may have been a bad Super Bowl pick yeah
well you got you got yes it is it was
Watson was better ok but I saw him run a
few time ran a few times he made some
decisions aggressive did all that snacks
is removable unmovable I mean unmovable
he's unbelievable and when they go
forward down with him gavel and
Tomlinson Hill and win just therefore
down and nickel they can get big and
nickel like that manda they force your
hand because they can play coverage
behind it and still stop the run that's
good let's see past concepts basic for
the Texans oline getting whooped verse
the run is what I wrote and then that
took away the play-action and all that
boot stuff that they like to do with
Watson I wrote end to the half 3rd
quarter Watson finally started to move
and he compromised coverage he's gonna
have to start doing this basically what
I wrote about them is he's gonna have to
start taking over games it's the only
one has to he has to he's gonna have to
start being DeSean we saw last year and
see how knowing Lori's gonna have to run
around because I don't think there's
enough past concepts there and his old
lines not gonna be reliable enough to
protect them all that's the reason I put
him in the Super Bowl is I thought
that's what we were gonna get yeah
Michael Jordan deshaun Watson yeah
alright so you take a little confidence
away from the Giants but you'd need
teams to rush five against them yeah I
mean I gotta see more the Giants are
still dangerous surprise Eli's good with
quick decisions underneath exactly just
don't give it to Bob why would you give
it to him excuse your burping that was
gross
all right so again we will have the show
on YouTube 8:00 p.m. tomorrow little
DeMarco Murray we have an informant we
have a show in Foreman breaking down
what is wrong with the Patriots he's an
unnamed person I can't give it away your
watch the show it figure out I'm gonna
do it as I can't really tell you that's
crazy
alright so hit us up on social items and
Lefko we did a little deep dive again
check out Atlanta Super Bowl
apparently the Docs and spreadsheets are
agreeing agreed I'm seeing some people
say hey you're really good about letting
yes all right I was angry to start the
podcast it's okay I mean I just like to
do my job sorry for Sims good but so
you're gonna say something I thought I
heard fender ik there for a second I
didn't know he kind of bumped in mine
okay sorry for Sims peace out homies
forfeiture
evening thanks to Jason Kelson everybody
for the lef koe man Jason Kelsey is the
man
we will holla holla holla at you
Wednesday 8:00 p.m. YouTube check out
the shims and Lefko show until then
holla holla holla holla you make me in a
better mood
you
[Music]